my talk of the table love him too Steve
Martin he does adorable things too yes
over the years he has starred in dozens
of movies but now he says he's focusing
his talents elsewhere including TV he's
also teamed up with Fame cartoonist that
would be Harry Bliss for a new Memoir of
sorts it's called I love this title
number one is walking my life in the
movies and other diversions so we caught
up with a pair in Martin's New York City
Apartment the other day for an afternoon
of behind-the-scenes stories drawing and
yep a little banjo playing we began
though with the cartoons or what the duo
calls diversions
could you read the one about the
centipede at the shoe store oh well
that's easy to read okay uh oh
I mean a centipede with a hundred feet
goes into a shoe store and the shoe
salesman just say uh-oh then there's
this one about a cat go ahead and search
me especially under the chin and belly
area well and my favorite might be
the baby I love the baby okay how would
you read that one Steve it's a couple
like doting over the baby and the baby
just thinks
I own you
didn't you feel that when your daughter
was absolutely yeah born in charge yeah
we should explain the title because I
always worried about the title because
it sounds arrogant and the picture on
the cover it looks a little it looks a
tad arrogant Mr Barton that's the way I
walk normally when you're doing a movie
Outdoors on location instead of saying
you know uh Tom Cruise is coming to the
set they'll say Steve Martin's coming
whatever they'll say
according to the call sheet one two
three four so Tom Cruise would be number
one so they would say number one is
walking so the public doesn't go Tom
Cruise yeah with me they go Steve Martin
so I'm curious about how the partnership
between the two of you came together did
you call him did he call you were you
guys old friends we were introduced uh
like a blind date uh in a way oh we
didn't meet each other I said one of the
great things about working with Harry is
we never see each other so he lives in
New Hampshire and I live here and uh no
we were uh put together by the New
Yorker I grew up watching SNL so uh the
blue she and Aykroyd and Chevy Chase and
all that whole cast and Steve Dirty
Rotten Scoundrels there are certain
scenes in Steve's movies I've not really
said much of this to you over the few
years we've been doing this but there
are scenes that are some of the funniest
movies I've seen I've ever seen in films
look doctor he's so happy he's crying
I always think of a movie career it's
not like a bunch of movies
but a bunch of Clips you know and when
when you're summarized on television or
something they show clips so you've got
to have some really good clips and Steve
Martin has no shortage of good Clips
those aren't pillows foreign
[Music]
and don't forget to fasten your condom
how did you all decide what movies you
were going to include and how you were
going to do it
you go first Mr Martin please well you
you pick it according to what stories
you have so if Steve is telling me an
anecdote about uh Roxanne and he tells
me this it was filmed in British
Columbia in this town I'll look up the
town and do some research on what it
looked like and he can draw Jackie
onassis's apartment yes you know and I
don't have to describe it because you
could I mean I can tell him what was
there but the drawings are so complete
and full you know what I'm learning guys
about this book he gives you antidotes
and then it seems like you have to do a
lot of homework to research to get to
nail it just right I'll jump in because
it's not easy to remember these stories
well you have to sit there at night you
go oh yeah
let's talk about Three Amigos that
iconic picture of The Three Amigos and
then you make a point of saying this is
a ladder so you're not even sitting on
horses Steve you know a horse can be
tricky you get thrown off a horse you're
in trouble yeah so for photographs and
close-ups we would sit on ladders and
then we'd try to ride the ladders which
was sad and one of my favorite stories
in the book is Paul McCartney in music
that is an absolutely true story every
detail of that is true okay set that up
for us I was working with a produ I was
doing one of my banjo Bluegrass albums
and I'd written all the songs and the
producer Tony triska is a great banjo
player said you know who I hear singing
this song I said who he said Paul
McCartney I write him and I say you know
my producer thinks you should sing this
well he said why don't you sing it and I
said because I don't have a good voice
and I said look let me just make up a
demo of it I'll sing it on the demo and
so you can hear how the song goes and
I'll send it to you I get a call and he
says uh
you know I listened to the demo he said
when you said you couldn't sing I
thought you were being humble
and he said okay I'll do it he was the
most Charming
gigantic star I've ever met now it was
time to watch the multi-talented Masters
at work
is this one of your own compositions
what shall we call it Gail
doesn't that have a ring called Barbara
Walters
Harry Bliss Drew inspiration from my
figure eight I like loopy things
[Music]
okay all right Steve you have to come up
with a cat what's the caption about
um it's sold for under a million so I
don't like it
you said you lost interest in movies the
same time movies lost interest in you
tell me what I meant was you know movies
started to change
the the style became different they
became you know epics also you know I I
now have a family so so it was more
about family life as opposed to the love
of movies because you still seem to love
movies I do love movies but I also love
television I also love only murders in
the building but to care about a murder
mystery you need to care about the
person who was murdered who is Tim Kono
you know it's just a different kind of
thing and the the quality shifted Bliss
says this about his partnership with
Martin we always agreed that as long as
it's fun and it doesn't feel like work
because I love to draw yes and it's
Steve and he's funny and I love to
listen to him
uh we'll just keep doing it and Harry
let's talk about Harry because he's a
legendary cartoonist he's written and
Illustrated more than 20 children's
books wow and creator of couple dozen of
uh the covered New Yorker covers but the
thing about Stephen the banjo it was in
another room it's not like it was just
laying there and I when I was walking I
said oh Steve would you play the banjo
he goes I really don't think that's
necessary for the story I don't want to
be that guy that's like here listen to
me but it could just be a funny bit he
goes I I really don't want to do that
but groveling is very effective yeah so
he ended up doing he goes and now the
music's gonna need to match I go let the
team figure that and team figured that
out very well shout out to the team yeah
we put that together Matt kugelman great
great editing because that's hard to do
uh he was talking about the importance
of movie clips that are funny he's got a
lot of movie clips he does it's hard to
choose your face he's a legend but you
know what he says about his movies that
you have to do at least you have to wait
at least 10 years to see if it's really
good does it have legs oh really that's
that's according to Steve Martin and he
says you have to make at least 40 movies
to get five good ones so there's a lot
of wisdom about his thinking in the book
it's very well done the illustrations
are great the book is very 40 40 and
make five good ones a lot of directors
fly this morning wondering if they're
one of the five yeah no doubt about it
there's a question number one number one
is walking don't you like that title
it's a great time number one is you know
that's what we say when you walk into
the studio no that is not at all what
they say they say she's here she showed
up again number one is walking is on
sale now wherever you like to buy your
books